today the raids could actually with a
win ensure themselves that they would
have a spot in the postseason
right-hander luis patino making his 15th
start of the season the record four and
three the era 473 much better here at
home with a 3.38 earned run average and
like we were talking earlier you want to
see him attack this lineup this is a
potent lineup but you can't shy away
from it george springer the dh and
leadoff man
for the blue jays steps in first pitch
and he lines it into left and that ball
is
caught out there a sinking line drive a
rosarina got there and managed to keep
it in the glove to keep that ball in the
very edge of the webbing before he got
his hand on it
was something else ends up as a snow
cone and what a way to start this going
a one-out walk to bring vladimir
guerrero junior to the plate
has been consistent all season long
having a phenomenal year
first pitch swinging and he drills one
into left center for a base hit
simeon coming around to third on a long
single
by vladimir guerrero jr first pitch
swinging
just about
nobody in baseball does more on the
first pitch than vlady nobody hits good
velocity better than flatty this year
and we saw evidence of that on that
swing right there so the bases are
loaded with two gone you could do worse
than having lourdes gurillo jr coming up
in this kind of a spot he's been
phenomenal what he has done in the
second half
fly ball into right field
margot going back toward the track and
is there to make the catch
load them up but can't get them in
meriwether needs to have a couple of
good inning hopefully and charlie
montoya was asked how long is he going
to go he said i'm not going to tell you
if he gets out easily he'll get more
outs to get and you know he'd like to
have him
of course throw one in him but boy if he
could give you two innings and shut out
this race team early in this balkan
that'd be a real blessing for the blue
jays and he's got two men on with one
out now for yandy diaz
swung on fouled off
guerrero might have a play and he does a
good catch over the shoulder by vlady
for a very big second out guerrero never
gave up on it and he makes a catch with
plenty of room to spare so now austin
meadows a 25 homer 100 rbi guy here in
the five spot the pitch to meadows is
drilled down the left field line pretty
well struck racing into the corner
guriel is there and he makes the catch
in front of the 315 marker to retire
meadows and the side the raised with a
major threat two men in scoring position
for g-man choi
and there is ball four wide
and the bases are loaded
with nobody out for yandy diaz
and he lines it into center dyson's
gonna back up to make the catch tag at
third lau will score and a rosarito will
advance to third on a hot shot by drive
off the bat of yandy diaz
and the raids take a one-nothing lead
and here's austin meadows austin meadows
lowest ground ball percentage in major
league baseball get the ball in the air
get that run home
there's a drive
high
deep
and
gone
home run off the bat of austin meadows
three-run shot number 26 for meadows
gives him a hundred and three runs
batted in well he got an airborne
and at least that run and a couple of
more
oh that's exactly what this ray's
offense needed two ounce with margot
aboard francisco mejia the eighth hitter
to come to the plate
that's headed for the gap deep into left
center toward the deep part of the park
pounding off the wall
margot
will score
and that ball
i think hit
the top of the wall
to land
on that ledge yeah i think so that's
gonna be a double that margaux
is gonna have to go back to third here
so it's a double for mejia cost him a
run batted in the second and third
taylor walls
ground ball toward the middle
that's gonna go through
both runs will score
and walls get the job done
taylor walls driving in two and it's a
six run in it and a third one out jaundy
diaz would have an opportunity to pick
up this run ground ball up the middle
base hit that will get a rose arena home
diaz driving in his second run of the
day
it's 7-0 tampa bay
here is vladimir guerrero guerrero is
single then he has five to right field
one two that's ripped past the third
baseman and up the left field line
vladi's got another base set and he
wants one more he'll jog into second
everything he hits is a hot shot he's
got a two hit day so it's runners on the
corners with one down tay oscar
hernandez is the batter for the blue
jays hit by a pitch and he's also
grounded out
[Applause]
and this one popped up into center field
kier myers settling underneath it he'll
make the catch guerrero's going to tag
and come in to score a sac fly for
hernandez giving the blue jays their
first run of the ball game daniel pick
up another rbr that gives him 109 for
the season jansen pinch hit back in the
fifth inning for reese maguire
ground ball third
flag down by diaz he turns and throws to
first and that will take care of chance
and how about that for a little toss
across the diamond i love it the back
foot floater
just in time
backing up get a hop and as the rush
starts to close in he floats it out over
the middle to g-man choi
for a first down
dyson still at first with two outs
here's marcus simeon
and he is out on strikes could not check
on the off speed they're down to the
last six out two in scoring position for
the blue jays and a chance for lourdes
gorilla jr
he powered that one at 99 by him and
strikes him out and pete on the verge of
getting out of this thing he got him
after all of that he comes back with a
slider
and strikes him out leading off the
bottom of the eighth kevin keermeyer
keermeyer is hit by that pitch
and uh we know what has gone on with all
of that kirby are not happy
being escorted up that first base line
by the plate umpire
bruce dreckman
and both benches now
are emptying kevin cash is hot he wants
bruce strechman to know that that was on
purpose and he should be kicked out of
the game yeah joe has just said you got
to go so barracky
is out of the game walker's hot now
let's see here kelly montoya is trying
to hold him back
and he just got kicked out
walker got kicked out too and charlie
montoya is going to try to come between
his pitching coach and joe wetz and joe
west is having none of them so the rays
an out away from making the postseason
for the seventh time in club history and
george springer will be up with the
bases empty the pitch on its way
swinging a grounder towards short walls
has it throws across raceway raceway
race win
for the third straight season your tampa
bay rays are going to the postseason
you